[Music]
this week's video is going to be all
about the health benefits of green tea
i've seen some overblown claims so we're
going to parse through and figure out
what's what also stay tuned to the end
of the video to get tips on how to make
the healthiest cup of tea possible tea
is one of those rare beverages that's
pretty much universally accepted by
science as a healthy one but just
remember as with everything in life you
can have too much of a good thing so
don't overdo it with the green tea
the number one thing that makes green
tea so good for you is that it's loaded
with healthy nutrients all of these
bioactive polyphenols are awesome for
your health you may have heard of some
of them known as flavonoids or catechins
and what those are just
antioxidant what antioxidants do is
prevent free radical damage to your body
and free radical damage to your body
over time causes cancer but let me break
that down a bit
i know all of you have faucets at home
whether it's in your bathroom or in your
kitchen some of those faucets have rust
on them the rust is a direct result of
that free radical damage we always talk
about now antioxidants prevent that rust
from forming so think of antioxidants as
the rust prevention within our own
bodies yes
that's awesome within media it's been
mentioned before that those who drink
green tea have lower rates of cancer and
it's been theorized that it has
something to do with the huge amount of
antioxidants found within green tea we
have to not get too excited by this fact
because this is only a correlation and
not a causation yes it's good to drink
green tea but no it's not going to cure
and prevent all types of cancer second
great point about green tea
if you got stinky breath
maybe you should try some green tea but
that's none of my business the nutrients
within green tea that we just mentioned
on this last point known as catechins do
a great job of inhibiting and killing
certain types of bacteria in fact
studies were done and proved that
bacteria known to cause bad breath
within your mouth was killed by drinking
green tea also when you have less of
that specific bacteria you have less
plaque so green tea also decreases the
risk of developing a cavity point tray
about green tea
it does a great job of giving you stable
energy without all the jitters it has
about 30 to 50 milligrams of caffeine
which is roughly half a cup of coffee
you're still focused you're still
stimulated but you don't have that
jittery feeling that you get with a big
cup of coffee another nutrient within
green tea that works together with
caffeine to boost your brain function is
called l-theanine its benefit is that it
gives your brain relaxation without the
added sedation or drowsiness that come
along with other relaxing agents
while we've seen in animal and lab
models that it increases your good
cholesterol and lowers your bad
cholesterol what we found in animal lab
and human trials is that green tea
lowers your blood pressure and if you've
watched my hypertension video you know
how important it is to keep your blood
pressure under control point number five
green tea can help you burn fat
well maybe this is more of an individual
case-by-case basis thing because not all
studies agree on this but there is a
promise of increased metabolism and fat
oxidation essentially fat burning some
of the lab models have shown a decrease
in new blood vessel formation within
your fat stores meaning that it
literally takes away the vital nutrition
for your fat and makes it die kicking
that fat spot
point number six
animal and lab models both show that
catechins the nutrient we keep
mentioning over and over again decrease
the risk of you developing alzheimer's
and parkinson's disease science isn't
clear on why this occurs but it's
theorized that it has something to do
with the decrease in the development of
plaque within the brain if that doesn't
encourage you to take a sip i don't know
what will point seven now this is the
game changer this is the one that
everyone gets excited about
green tea may increase your lifespan
there's been a ton of research done on
this some studies even have forty
thousand participants that show those
who drink three to five cups of tea a
day have an increased life span have a
decreased all-cause mortality that means
dying from anything have decreases in
heart disease decreases in strokes but
before we get too excited we need to
remember correlation versus causation
just because those who drink green tea
live longer it doesn't mean green tea is
the sole thing that's responsible for
that effect so yes enjoy your green tea
but don't think you're gonna live
forever here's how you create the
healthiest cup of tea possible don't add
green tea directly to boiling water as
it destroys those healthy catechins
we've been talking about don't go decaf
because the decaffeination process hurts
more of the nutrients found within green
tea add lemon into your tea as it aids
in the absorption of some of these
nutrients finally don't cheap out go for
the good premium stuff as it contains
more of the healthy nutrients we've been
talking about all along i need you to
know this don't buy into the bs
supplements that take green tea extract
and claim that it has miracle health
benefits they do not the real thing is
always healthier than the supplement
form as always thanks for watching audio
check one two on the mc mic with the
emerald green scrubs atticans and what
basically
which is just an ekg but for the brain
do people know what an ekg is catechins
that neutrin we've mentioned many times
animal models and lab modeling even t
bro can i interest you in a cup of tea
from a squirrel cup
[Music]
what each and every one of the
politicians needs
is a nice cup
of honest tea
i got a better one what do you call a
dentist who doesn't like tea
dennis
was that good kids
don't try this at home
do you get it
[Music]